[Music]
so you think animals are cute and
adorable like mr. bananas over here
wrong animals are dangerous and deadly
[Music]
what is up everybody
Anna Mack here for anime uproar and
welcome to the second installment or
brand new series crazy anime theories
that actually make sense in the last
video we talked about the theory that
total huh cocoon it doesn't really exist
and this time we will be looking at the
crazy theory that the you a trader is
actually Koji Koda
aka the petting Hiro anima I'm going to
argue that even though Koda appears to
be a kind and gentle giant that is just
the perfect cover for the you a traitor
that's right Kochi Kona is the you a
trader and I've got proof ish now even
though the word crazy is in the title of
these videos and even though I said in
the first video that these theories are
improbable and they're mostly just for
fun we still had a bunch of people in
the comments section of the last video
getting super triggered about the theory
and to that all I can say is mission
accomplished and a lot of people also
got triggered after they saw the
infamous Justin why in the comments
section of the last video and to that
all I have to say is Justin why so
serious but seriously on YouTube in 2018
the success of a video is no longer
measured by likes or views it is
measured by whether or not that video
has a comment from Justin why and I for
one will be really disappointed if I
don't see Justin why in the comments
section of this video and now let's get
to the Kochi Kota you a trader
conspiracy in the last video I invited
you guys to give me your own crazy
theories on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar links in the description
and if I like them I will feature them
in a future video the reason why I asked
you guys to go to social media instead
of the comments section is that usually
YouTube comments are filled with
irrelevant stuff troll comments Justin
why and so on so I can't really keep up
with every single suggestion you pose
here whereas on Twitter and Instagram
it's a lot easier because trolls usually
don't bother to go there but I did
happen to come across this comment on a
different video that really got me
thinking so kudos to Jonathan on that
and as it happens blah boon Justin had
the same idea over on Instagram the big
question that Jonathan raises is how did
Koji Koda past the UA entrance exam in
the first place
his quirk and a voice also known as a
bug for Ola how do you like Dominic's I
finally came up with one before you by
the way if you're not aware of my friend
Knox talk who he makes absolutely
hilarious MHA content be sure to check
him out after this video link in the
description and by all means feel free
to spam the comments of his video with
things like bug foot ole or coda lied to
us whatever's gonna really confuse him
and make him think of what is happening
but back on topic quotas quirk and a
voice allows him to talk to and control
animals but how could that possibly be
useful at the entrance exam where you
had to defeat a large robot villains
I've heard some people say that maybe
Koda was able to find a bunch of rats in
the area and command them to attack the
robots and eat through their wiring and
that would make sense in a real urban
environment a big city will definitely
have a ton of rats living in the sewers
and other places that we'd rather not
think about except the UA entrance exam
does not take place in a real city but
in a battle arena that is made to look
like an urban setting but it is actually
all artificial rats live in big cities
because there are a lot of people living
there so there is a lot of garbage and
waste which means food for the rats in
an artificial urban setting there will
be no one actually living there so there
will be no reliable food source for the
rats so if we rule out rats based on
that there are of course insects
naturally bug food all but it's unlikely
that they would be able to take down
robots especially since we know that
Koda is afraid of insects so it's
doubtful if at that point in his life he
would have been willing to even consider
insects as an OP
the other possibility is birds and we
did see Khoda using them during the
provisional license exam mark against
students from rival schools but regular
students and robots are clearly
different and the only way that Koda
might have been able to take down robots
with birds is by commanding flocks and
flocks of birds to slam into the robots
and by the time common birds like
pigeons which are quite small and frail
did enough damage to take down robot
villains literally thousands of these
birds would die
his Kota really capable of committing
mass bird murder just to get into the UA
if he is then he is probably worse than
a traitor he is the type of merciless
psychopath that would make even
Hitchcock both cry and soil himself at
the same time and if we rule out rats
insects and birds the only other option
is well probably not the only option but
I'm saying that for dramatic effect the
only other option is that Koji Kota used
his ability for manipulating and
controlling animals to manipulate and
control the U a principle mezu who is
himself a highly intelligent animal but
an animal nonetheless could it really be
a coincidence that in a school where the
principal just happens to be one of the
extremely rare cases of an animal with a
quirk the one student with the power to
control animals ends up getting into
class 1a the top class in the top school
in the country and all of that despite
the fact that Kota squirt seemed to be
very ill suited for the urban
environment that the entrance exam
placed him in and so Kota
with his quirk being what it is doesn't
get into class 1c or 1b
he gets straight into 1a and yet the guy
who can control actual people he Toshi
Shinto ends up in class 1c is this
really a coincidence I mean yeah it
definitely could be and so far coda has
been presented as a very gentle kind and
shy person who loves his mom and nature
and animals what could be more pure and
innocent than that but if you really
think about it isn't that the perfect
cover story for a spy who would ever
suspect someone as nice as coda of being
a villain or a traitor I bet that the
and section of this video will be
flooded with people saying things like
how dare you Koji Kota is pure and good
Koji Kota is best boy Koji Kota is loved
and that is exactly why Kota is the
perfect spy and all of you who commented
that stuff fell right into his trap
congratulations you played yourself
seriously though just imagine for a
moment the power that the you a traitor
would have if he had the ability to
manipulate the principal of the school
at will and if you combine that with how
innocent and shy Kota appears to be if
he was the traitor he would have the
perfect quirk and the perfect cover to
get all the information he needs without
ever being detected and Kota being the
traitor would also be a great twist
precisely because the vast majority of
people probably wouldn't ever suspect
him so they wouldn't see it coming and
so they would all be very surprised and
of course entertained by the prospect so
is Koji Kota with his quirk bug for all
definitely the you a traitor we
obviously can't say for sure right now
but he could be it's possible and that
is enough to get this crazy theory its
own video that way if he doesn't turn
out to be the traitor
I can just say oh yeah of course that
video was just for fun but if he does
end up being the traitor then I still
get to take the credit for figuring it
out you see how that works and if that's
the kind of anime video series that
sounds fun to you you can leave a like
to let me know and you can subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you can
know every time a new video in this
series comes out feel free to share your
feedback and your crazy theories down in
the comments and before we go I want to
share some of your crazy Theory
contributions from Twitter and Instagram
if you'd like to be featured in a future
video just hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime lore as I said
earlier over on Instagram bla boo Justin
had the same idea that Koji Koda could
be the traitor because his quirk allows
him to control mezu Mach table 786 bxc
says I believe that the traitor has to
be someone who acts weak but in reality
is as strong as all might probably
Moneta while I definitely agree that
minute.i is a strong
is all mine and that might be the next
video in this series as I said I think
that coda also fits this description
perfectly
no one thinks of coda when thinking
about who the strongest students are no
one thinks of him as anything more than
a kind and gentle giant and that is the
perfect cover story for the trader
Darklight five nine five three says what
if the one punch man universe is the
distant future of the my hero academia
universe and what if Saitama is the 12th
and current user of one for all so that
would mean the quark one for all is what
made Saitama as strong as he is in the
three years that he spent training to be
a hero he actually spent mastering the
quark one for all this is definitely an
interesting crazy theory and I actually
thought about something like this myself
because I watched the first season of
both of these anime around the same time
and I thought it was interesting how
they both dealt with a society where
heroes protect the citizens from
dangerous villains one of the two quirks
that came together to create one for all
is a quirk that stock files energy so we
could assume that one for all will keep
getting stronger the more users it has
obviously this theory can never be
confirmed because these are two
completely different franchises but this
is exactly the type of crazy theory that
fans love to talk about so I can
definitely get behind it over on Twitter
savage swordsman says that baku goes
true father might actually be the
villain muscular and the man that we see
at the house is a fake and this could
have happened because buckle goes mom
didn't want to tell Baku go the hard
truth that his father was actually a
villain to be honest when I first saw
muscular in the anime I definitely
couldn't help but think that his
appearance including his face hair style
and hair color were pretty similar to
Baku I didn't think about this while
reading the manga because the manga is
black and white but the similarity
definitely crossed my mind when I
finally saw muscular in the anime my
guess is that if muscular was really a
more important character and Baku gross
secret father he would have had more
importance to the story instead of just
getting rekt by Deku and arrested but
hey you never know muscular might make a
reappearance sometime in the future
Isaac McGee also mentioned the theory
that one punch man could be the world of
my hero academia but in the distant
future again I think this is one of
those really interesting crazy anime
and theories that could never be
confirmed but is still fun to think
about iron rose has a theory that
shigaraki and deku are related possibly
cousin this is because all might
mentioned a resemblance between decos
mom and Nana and of course monona Nana
is she Gaddafi's grandmother the fact
that potion ariake mentions how much ink
Oh reminds him of Nana definitely seemed
important to me it felt like more than
just a random remark shigaraki is Nana's
grandson so if it turned out that Inka
was related to Nana then deco and
shigaraki would end up being cousins and
that would definitely spice up their
rivalry even more we'll need to find
some more evidence for this before
talking about it seriously but
definitely something to think about and
finally knocks Taku on Twitter just
posted a Lord Twigg o meme and of course
it got 62 freaking likes man this is so
sad Alexa play and on that note thank
you all so much for watching and until
next time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you